[Música]
o que conta uma história é de família
mas a família passa de uma história
também de vida de humanidade
esse meu avô nasceu em 1902 nasceu em
bremen na alemanha premium porto muito
importante a mãe os momentos de navios
de cargas e ele passou a juventude
estudando técnica na volta como
consertar vez passou a primeira guerra e
um pouquinho de história depois da
primeira guerra de egos tratado de
versalhes alimento num caos absoluto vou
contar aqui sai de manhã com uma caixa
de sapato de bilhões de marcos contra
pães e voltava de tarde o dia seguinte
uma caixa e meia para a identificação e
depois da guerra com essa pressão toda
ele decide pegar um navio em bremen e
aportar no brasil
aqui ele conhece um brasileira em
petrópolis icasa tem quatro filhos e uma
delas é batizado de brasília o amor dele
o país
o mais incrível que quando começa o
movimento do nazismo e 3 por volta de 4
que lista de manhã a mãe e dois irmãos
ele é mais novo dos três recebe doado
aos irmão mais velho uma carta
convocando que ele volte à alemanha para
pilotar os famosos boots eu sou marina
de autorização para poder se juntar
aquele orgulho da pátria quer uma na
verdade não era uma febre se assemelha
muito ao muitas coisas acontecendo país
hoje ou no mundo com as febres de
acreditar mas verdades absolutas e se
recusa a voltar pra minha mãe e ele
simplesmente deserdado ele nessa carta
de desvinculação do irmão como emoção
tão forte porque ele ele tira ele perde
toda a parte da herança ele perde o
direito de voltar à família ele perde o
contato com toda a sua seu laço familiar
e fica isolado brasil com os seus filhos
e sua esposa
paradoxalmente tempo dele é ficar no
brasil e um pacifista time contava ele
me contava também que a casa deles não
só em petróleo mas também no rico não se
muda era constantemente pichada com
suásticas e ele ah
sistematicamente acordado no meio da
noite a ser chamado à delegacia para
depor por suspeita de estupro em
espionagem ou informações privilegiadas
para os alemães
logo depois da guerra passou décadas
depois ele consegue junto com o solo
alemão encontrar um irmão vivo em bremen
e volta para bremen volta problema é
quando ele volta pra casa de volta ao
brasil ele encontrou o irmão é uma
imensa e se encontra depois de anos a
mãe morreu irmão mais velho morreu no
centro de berlim eo ballet luthor pelo
nazismo ele volta ao brasil uma
parafernalha e outro adolescente na
época de cruz de ferro a de medalhas diz
para fins
isso cria um encantamento eu andava em
casa e investindo sim parecia e sensuais
que se no caps vestindo capacetes indo
pra mim no acampamento aquela aquele
desenho meu pai me alertando isso não é
assim
isso não é assim quando comecei a
estudar ao jornalismo comecei a
fotografar que vai entender um pouco
mais da do que era esse movimento todo
entende que existe uma diferença entre a
segunda guerra mundial e que estão nos
campos de concentração
a questão simples o local que nós
conhecemos
não foi uma questão de guerra não há
motivos militares para o local se
existido era perseguição contra pessoas
não só judeus mas ciganos de sinuiju
vários homossexuais pessoas contrárias
ao regime
o que nós fizemos em renata da mulher
começamos uma árdua o a trabalho junto
aos campos principais campos não só na
alemanha mas em praga e na polônia de
tentar buscar ir prá lá e prá entender o
que está acontecendo o que acontecia no
mundo com isso se esses campos
cemitérios sem filhos menores de
recordação sim a forma de denúncia pra
você não esquecer o que aconteceu no
passado sim por dois anos consecutivos e
ficou tentando conseguimos o apoio de
companhias aéreas de consulados e
principalmente um salvo-conduto dos três
principais campos para nós irmos lá e
fotografar coisas que os turistas não
podem se ter uma idéia a a diretoria já
os civis nos falava que uma companhia de
lingerie
francesa entrou para o time fez uma
campanha que a gente tinha dentro do
campo de concentração é enfrentar os
inscrição para fotografar modelos com
calcinha e sutiã dentro de um campo de
concentração
então para nós entrar em aos civis hoje
você tem todo um sistema de segurança
para tentar preservar a memória muito
dolorida e é muito comum de self assim
muito bom se tivesse os céus dos campos
sorrindo obrigando os trens por
desconhecimento completo porque cada vez
mais afastamento da realidade está
acontecendo porque a gente fez a gente
conseguiu ir para a europa nós passamos
15 dias trabalhando há 15 dias e nós
fazemos 10 anos casado falei vamos
viajar agora dez anos casados presentes
vamos hoje planta terezita é a opção que
a organização foi um presente pouco de
grego
mas fomos a renata escrevendo e
fotografando e aí começamos a perceber
que fotografar um campo e entrar no
espaço memória desse é muito é muito
forte é muito forte porque não há vida
não a sua tristeza um silêncio absoluto
depois de 15 dias
1800 registros voltamos de dos campos
decidimos fazer uma coisa que não dá voz
a essas vozes a voz as fotos
o que nós fizemos vamos entrevistar as
pessoas que passaram por aí pra isso que
a gente fez
envelheceu as fotos o deixou na forma
preta e branca pra passar um ar de
atemporalidade elas podiam ser visto em
qualquer lugar em qualquer época seria
por isso nesses 45 um filme colorido e
aí começamos a entrevistar as pessoas
que passaram por esses lugares que
sobreviveu estava no brasil é que se
consegue perceber que a foto funcionou
como um mecanismo de memórias de trazer
uma dor tão aguardada ser expurgada você
vê assim velhos pessoas idosas chorando
copiosamente conduzir uma foto eu passei
por aqui para os atletas
eu via que visse corredor aqui tinha um
cachorro que late pra mim aqui tinha um
pedaço da chuva batalha que eu vou bater
com de batatas e basta segundinha onde a
gente esconde uma batata
assim para poder comer isso extremamente
forte como nós começamos essa viagem
primeiro campo xavi house dentro da
alemanha roberto de 36 vocês têm a
guerra começou em 39 em 36 alemanha
nazista contratou uma série de empresas
tecnologia pra fazer um censo da
alemanha para saber quem era judeu quem
era quem tinha o sobrenome quem tinha
negócios que começou mandar pra esse
campo é uma antiga cervejaria dentro da
alemanha há meia hora de berlim as
pessoas pra lá existe execução ainda
câmeras de gás mas sim prisões
solitárias dos pontos mais marcantes foi
nós vencemos a cozinha do campo e ver
que eles colocavam exemplo a comida como
disciplina trabalhar na cozinha do campo
de chás em house era um privilégio os
prisioneiros porque eles podiam roubar
cascas de batata e banda boca chupar a
chance de sobreviver numa cozinha do
campo função era muito maior que vê no
campo porque a cota de calorias por dia
para cada prisioneiro já em terceiro sem
calorias por dia 100 calorias que este
tipo de escuta o lado mitologicamente os
alemães
essa é uma foto que mostrando disciplina
limpezas batata sendo limpas e aí um
momento alguns prisioneiros têm a chance
de pintar o que não conseguem ver lá
fora se observar marcas de tiro foi a
libertação dos gols entrar na cozinha
para libertar pelo clube é o último
lugar que os peões ficarão seguros
algumas vezes chances de pintar na
cozinha e expressar uma dor muito grande
isso antes da guerra acontecer é mais
paradoxal mais importância e o campo o
libertad em 45 jogos e por essa porta os
que dormiram se saíram bem me lembro que
o inter falou eu sei essa fechadura com
a beira do rio de janeiros foi o momento
que sentir livre
então sim são pequenos detalhes das
fotos que trouxeram uma força uma emoção
das sobreviventes que é e precisava
falar e escrever
escrever comigo para mostrar de como era
forte emoção
de lá fomos um campo emblemático chamado
thesing em paga quando os alemães
começam a descobrir mais aces que
existiu fortunas guardados alemães
judeus que viviam na alemanha o que eles
fazem fazem o modelo cria uma cidade
hitler tinha uma cidade para os judeus
foi chamado de terezín que essa
propaganda venha para o despacho vem
prolongar se possa plantar lugar se
possa ler é um lugar maravilhoso estar
em interesse em o incrível que os
prisioneiros chegassem chegava aqui
chegava em vagões primeira classe com
soho melhor roupa entrava no vagão
berlim em praga pra a terezin com sua
melhor roupa melhor vestimenta com os
bolsos cheios de ouro diamantes e
relógios que tinha na bagagem quando
chegava encontrar com isso encontrava em
uma cela coletiva as roupas eram tiradas
eram dados uniformes e agora de
prisioneiros comuns porque isso foi
feito porque o gmail começou de
desconfiar de alguma coisa acontecendo é
muito forte porque começou sob muita
gente começou rumores que estava tendo
torturas execuções na alemanha
terezinha um campo que volta e meia com
os vermelhinhos sempre está tudo bem que
eles fazem é botar os meninos bonitos
maquiados mulheres com button a bem
investido será uniforme e apresentar
essas pessoas por lá mas na verdade esse
campo seus espelhos foram colocados
pelos nazistas estão muito acima da
altura para passar a ideia que os
brasileiros tinham uma boa vida de um
campo chamado terezin mas não não tinha
roupas lavadas as outras eram colocados
numa maca extingui lá pô
os uniformes nem como positivo os
uniformes que usavam uma máquina de
vapor
eles vestiram as roupas molhadas ainda a
ideia tentar matar os piolhos que eram
muito constante e com a vida aqui uma
força fantástica que é como a propaganda
pode enganar as pessoas
é um cinema e televisão em que passava
um filme em que prisioneiros jogam
contra
o dados e aí aqui sentar os setores da
cruz vermelha e assistindo a esses
filmes fala aqui é um ótimo lugar para
os alemães que se vê é um perfeito lugar
aqui estou feliz aqui eles vivem bem mas
não era só uma propaganda nazista no
cinema existe hoje e que em abril se
essa porta para nós era um link a gente
tinha quase 30 sobreviventes porque
tinha uma dor no olhar
ele havia sobrevivido ficar no campo o
que tinha uma carga de tristeza quando
batalhas filme mas mando nada foi assim
as pessoas que percebiam tinha uma
fraude por esse campo sob uma solução o
campo está mexendo demais ou ainda
reclamando ea solução era terminar esse
é um campo subterrâneo que sai do da
fortaleza de terezín para o muro
lamento porque terezinha no entreposto
na verdade para o ceviche filó
emblemático campo mais forte aqui as
pessoas colocadas e fuzilados voltando
terminam 13 indo em direção aos 20 para
cracóvia onde o papa nasceu e descobre
que lá um cara muito importante na vida
gentil da vida da humanidade como
exemplo a china derrotou na fábrica para
salvar 1.200 deus da morte
e essa fábrica são hoje um museu
permanente dos objetos achados pelas
pessoas que perderam a vida como
carrinhos de bebê brinquedos todos os
objetos foram achados unidos e foram à
retomados pelos alemães em que enviaram
os deus para os campos são recordações
de uma vida inteira documentos
brinquedos objetos e aí o próprio singer
é atrás as panelas que os primeiros
vazio que eu sei que não é verdade pra
nada só uma forma de dar uma desculpa o
governo alemão nazista que é via se uma
produção no campo mas é meramente pra
constar que estava lá fazendo
trabalhando e assim durante toda a
guerra e salvou a vida de 1.200 judeus
ea gente entra no ponto mais pra mim é
mais forte da história ao seguinte
pênalti aos 20 serão complexo gigantesco
à imagine cup
expandiu cresceu a conquistou
territórios frança grécia hungria a
entrando pela rua dentro elas lugar
maior para colocar as pessoas então fez
um campo gigantesco que foi altamente
planejado para receber muita gente
inicialmente se criou
aos 25 um que é construído com tijolos
cuenca as pessoas chegavam eram
fotografadas
só que o volume de negócios aumentou
tanto tanto tanto tanto que não dá mais
pra fotografar
agora crianças velhos e mulheres eram
tatuados entrava por o campo esse boato
agem rapidamente feita no braço porque
essa primeira fase é o seguinte pedido
de expedição e 0 fotografar votados
uniformes já aos 22min renal e são
tatuados aqui funcionou o antigo
hospital mostra trabalhava dizer bem
dele e nós vamos manter se muito de uma
sobrevivente pela professora da minha
filha é minha mãe e tinha no sangue para
saber se o sangue judeu ou católico há
como se o alguns anos sem provar se é
sua a sua ajuda o católico protestante
era mandado do centro de pesquisas da
alemanha para saber se o sangue era
verdadeiramente os homens tinham suas
calças abertas da rua para saber se fica
utilizados eram preso
o que eu disse essa época foi um imenso
a contrabando digitar esticados para
salvar os homens quando estava parado na
rua tinha que abrir a calça e agora eu
tenho um atestado que eu tinha que ser
usado o tipo de doença venérea isso
virou um tempo muito forte depois os
alemães descobriram os nazistas e
tomaram certificados ensino para
informação diária onde as pessoas que
não cumpriram ou fazer alguma coisa
errada era enforcado aqueles trilhos
esses três levavam dias dias em
progresso da grécia até ao serviço da
polônia
levamos quatro dias
ligado sem água sem nada
a câmara de gás aos 20 o último a câmara
de gás cresceu tanto o volume de gente
foi para os campos a suas quer quatro
câmeras de gás
essa câmera dava conta o executava
centenas de pessoas por dia
dois anos depois que ela foi aberta a se
criou quatro câmeras com 1.205 sessões
por dia
aí vocês vêem aqui se têm passado por
aqui
as pessoas selecionadas se ele passasse
por aqui era o vagão de velhos crianças
inúteis e diante das câmeras de porque
todas as pessoas no fundo
o relator é o trem que significava que
ele ia direto para a câmara de gás
quem passar no meio de um barracão para
selecionar somente podia trabalhar se
podia ficar no campo e assim por diante
essa virava é meramente virar isso para
poder aplicar penas legais ou para a
seleção
um banheiro coletivo pessoas e depois
tinham seis minutos depois ao banheiro
todos juntos aos barracões positivas
construção sem barracões e aí eu fecho a
questão é por que um projeto como esse a
os dias de hoje é muito pouco tempo 74
anos mas não pode esquecer a hoje as
migrações do mundo as questões de
territorialidade as questões raciais as
questões de intolerância assim sinais de
uma forma em que a europa está se
tornando cada vez mais uma maior gênio
européia é impedir migrantes chegar à
europa
a síria está devastada brasil como
milhões movimentos políticos em relação
à questão de somos direita-esquerda
nazismo direita e esquerda não existe na
minha memória foi criado porque é um
menu el credo belém pa tirania e vítimas
da guerra
vítimas da guerra algumas pessoas se
organizam afar força dos homens contra
as populações mais fracas apenas um
recado para que não esqueçam jamais não
é sobre guerra não é sobre racismo sobre
a humanidade
se nós não nos atentarmos para o
movimento diário de proteger a
integridade humana
a gente pode cair no caos de barbárie ea
barba muito próximo de uma uma virada de
mesa e assim é termina uma história que
virou livro
gente muito obrigado foi uma honra ter
sede
[Aplausos]